China has the largest high-speed rail
network in the world spanning over 40
000 kilometers and of the 10 fastest
trains in the world four are in China
and China's busiest high-speed train the
Beijing Shanghai rail runs 217 miles per
hour the U.S however tells a much
different story its high-speed rail
system spans 735 kilometers and its
fastest train Amtrak's acella Express
goes just 150 miles per hour and only
for a few minutes on part of the track
since 2008 China has rapidly built up
its high-speed rail network the US in
that time has had several High-Speed
Rail projects shelved or delayed here's
how the US has fallen behind China in
High-Speed Rail technology
one key difference between the U.S and
China has to do with the tracks the
trains run on in the case of the U.S as
we can see a lot of the north sister
corridors are based on hundreds years of
the old tracks there are also tunnels
and a curvatures and bridges that are
really owed that cannot really allow the
trains to run at a faster speed these
tracks were originally built for Freight
and passenger trains to use at the same
time so they have many points of
intersections and crossings and the
Acela runs on this track but China has
tracks that are dedicated to High-Speed
Rail they are really requires to have a
more smoother curves has also the needed
to have a more slower gradients and so
that allowed the trains to roam smoothly
and safely one of the reasons trains in
America can't reach their top speeds is
because of how the tracks are designed
even though the trains are capable for
Amtrak to run 186 they'll never see more
than 160 miles per hour because the
infrastructure is still being developed
and isn't quite there yet it comes down
to Curves on the tracks many
conventional passenger trains in the U.S
only operate 10 to 15 miles per hour
faster than freight trains on the curved
portion of tracks but China built its
High-Speed Rail on elevated tracks
traveling on what's called viaducts so
the tolerance is in high speed are
pretty pretty precise pretty tightly
defined and so the track and overhead
wires need to be designed in a way to be
able to allow those higher speeds
there's also a difference in where
stations are located in China stations
for high-speed rails are located in both
suburban and rural areas of the country
whereas in the U.S stations are
primarily located in urban centers like
New York City Boston and Washington DC
when you're looking to identify where a
high speed line should go it really
starts with where are the two population
centers you're trying to connect and the
magic formula is really fine two City
pairs that have a minimum of three
million people on either side and a
distance of about two to five hundred
miles in order to achieve a higher speed
definitely a dedicated passenger rail
system is more needed despite the fact
that the US has been slow to develop
High-Speed Rail railroads actually used
to dominate Interstate Transportation
but that shifted during the mid 20th
century when the interstate highway
system was born since then American
history has been littered with
High-Speed Rail plans that never really
took off automobile and air travel and
the car travel is essentially become the
major modes of travel in the U.S to make
that kind of behavior change that
basically needs a lot of efforts to help
people understand why this is a need to
have another modes and what are the
benefits of that China's High-Speed Rail
however consistently had backing from
the government investing billion
millions of dollars including initial
partners with foreign firms contracts
were awarded on the condition that
foreign companies assemble the trains
and also trained Chinese Engineers so
they tried to understand that the
foreign Technologies how it works but
they're also trying to make certain
Innovations on top of that eventually
China developed its own train
Manufacturing Company the crrc and now
the crrc is one of the largest train
manufacturers in the world in the case
of china because it's a central
government system so large
infrastructure projects like high-speed
rail system can be really developed
based on a kind of consistent plan the
U.S has also had foreign companies come
to the country to develop a high-speed
rail network but it's been met with
several challenges take for example
Illinois back in 2019 Nippon shario of
Japan tried to build a high-speed rail
in the states however the companies
struggled to adapt designs to the US and
faced delays in getting new rail cars
and changing administrations doesn't
help California approved a plan in 2008
to build a high-speed rail network but
the project has been delayed because of
a lack of funding and inconsistent
support the train technology is already
here but what we're seeing right now in
the U.S at this specific moment in time
is not that dissimilar to what was
happening in Europe in the 1970s where
there was initially a lot of concern or
objection about trying to do something
new and it wasn't until the first system
started to be put in place and people
saw the real promise that you know high
speed was able to deliver on and then
once the political and public support
was behind it it really took off and
grew
foreign